[Applause]
[Music]
Freedom
like real like real
vandals destroying what they found
in front of
us we think there was a lack of security
and I wanted to tell you that all
those people who did this
will be found
they will realize that  democracy it
guarantees the right to freedom it
guarantees the right to free
communication and free expression but it also demands
that people respect
the institutions that were created to
strengthen democracy and these people make
these vandals that we could
call a fanatical nazi or a stalinist
of fanatics or rather
of fanatical fascists, you know, they did
what has never been done in the history of this
country